IT'S TIME FOR #HASHTAGWARS
A COUPLE OF DAYS OF AGO A
TWITTER USERS
@ALUNSFORD1209 SUGGESTED THE
HASHTAG "DIRTYNURSERYRHYMES."
WE LIKED THE IDEA, BUT ON
MONDAY'S WE STARTED DOING "RUIN"
SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#RUINANURSERYRHYME.
EXAMPLES WOULD BE LITTLE MISS
JIMMY BUFFET,
JACK AND JILL STARRING ADAM
SANDLER, ROW ROW V WADE.
SO 60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, AND
GO. EMILY.
>> LONDON BRIDGE IS FALLING DOWN
DUE TO TERRORISM.
>> THERE WAS AN OLD WOMAN WHO
LIVED IN A SHOE-- THANKS, OBAMA!
>> POINTS, POINTS.
EMILY.
>> DRY HUMPTY DUMPY.
>> THAT'S WHY HE CRACKED.
JONAH.
>> OLD MOTHER L RON HUBBARD.
>> JACK AND JILL WENT UP THE
HILL, BUT JACK SAYS THE SEX WAS
CONSENSUAL.
>> YES!
POINTS, JONAH.
>> JACK AND JILL WENT UP THE
HILL TO TALK ABOUT THE ABORTION.
>> SO YOU THINK HE PUSHED HER
DOWN THE HILL.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
>> I'LL FORGET ABOUT IT IF YOU
GIVE ME THE POINTS.
>> GEORGIE PORGIE PUTIN MAY CRY
OR MAY DIE.
>> THIRD EYE BLIND MICE.
>> YES!
DA-DA-DO-DO.
THAT'S ADORABLE!
>> ONCE YOU GO BA-BA-BLACK SHEEP
YOU NEVER GO BA-BA-BACK.